c'est un élan de créativité qui parcourt
cette classe de troisième depuis le mois
de septembre les élèves du collège
saint-augustin de saint germain ont les
options cinéma d'animation planche sur
un court métrage ces derniers sont
passés derrière l'écran le temps d'une
année pour s'initier aux techniques du
métier
l'expérimentation du dessin animé donc
la tablette lumineuse voilà ça ça a
beaucoup plu je pense aux élèves et puis
ensuite l'expérimentation c'est du
papier découpé donc cela consiste en
fait à fait à dessiner ce qu'on souhaite
désigner et puis à colorer à découper
ensuite à animer en fait au fur et à
mesure chaque jeudi pendant 1h30 29
élèves travaillent sur le projet tous
apportent leur pierre à l'édifice une
aventure collective pour ce film autour
de la végétation et de la civilisation
chacun était chargé de réaliser un
élément pour la vidéo personnages
paysages ou encore des corps moi mon
rôle c'est de faire des arbres parce
qu'on aura un paysage ou faudra faire
les arbres de la végétation j'ai découpé
beaucoup de de papier marron pour le
tronc et je le fais ça semblait en
faisant des blocs qui monteront de plus
en plus haut moi je vais dessiner un
animal donc un sanglier pas si on va
faire
un film dans une forêt donc il y en a
qui doit dessiner sous des arbres ou les
personnages ou d'autres animaux il y en
a qui étaient sont tout simplement les
décors les élèves sont accompagnés dans
leur projet par un intervenant après
avoir découvert les différentes étapes
de la réalisation d'un court métrage
d'animation ils sont initiés à la
technique image par image un dispositif
a été mis en place pour de l'animation
dit stop motion on va installer dès des
appareils photos qui vont permettre de
prendre image par image
la décomposition d'un mouvement là du
coup c'est le papier qui a été utilisée
pour pour la technique du film donc
découpé c'est à dire en fabrique des
pantins qui vont être animés parce
qu'ils sont articulés mais aussi des
éléments qui sont de différentes
couleurs de différentes épaisseurs de
papier qui vont évoluer dans les
paysages qui sont pensés le court
métrage sera diffusé sous forme de
projection mapping il sera projeté sur
la façade du collège saint-augustin lors
de la soirée d'inauguration d'un nouveau
bâtiment le 24 mai prochain